Beetlejuice 2 is finally in the works
it's Show Time Warner Brothers confirmed
that development on the movie had begun
at cinemacon 20123 soon after it was
announced that Wednesday's Jenna Ortega
had joined the cast reportedly playing
the daughter of Winona Ryder's character
from the first movie it has also been
reported that Michael Keaton is
returning to reprise his iconic turn as
Beetlejuice himself he'll be joined here
by returning cast members Ridder and
Katherine O'Hara with newcomer Monica
Bucci playing his wife and Justin
thorough playing an unknown character
apparently William defo is also set to
play some sort of afterlife cop
Beetlejuice 2 is tentatively earmarked
for a September 6th 2024 release date
but production delays caused by the SAG
after strike could feasibly push the
movie Down the Line